what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with fall of X the end of the
X-Men as we know them and this opens up
with the Declaration that the mutant
Massacre has officially begun which is a
great callback especially considering
this involves a variation of Mr Sinister
there is a whole story arc behind that
it's pretty amazing we'll cover it if
you guys are interested but the thing
about this is that orcas right the
anti-mutant organization that is a
combination of like Hydra Advanced idea
mechanics former Shield agents and so on
and so forth they orchestrated an attack
on the mutant population and those
mutants that they didn't kill they
forced off to Mars what they're doing
here is launching a kind of rewriting of
history and more or less propaganda
where they're putting out this idea that
mutants had killed a portion of humanity
which were on the island of krakowa
during the X-Men Gala right their great
big huge mutant based kind of massive
event that they all hold and Firestar is
one of the very few mutants that
actually rallied to their side in fact
the only mutant that sided with orcas
now in the last video that we covered
during the events of the X-Men Hellfire
Gala that what Gene gray had done before
she died in The Assault on the X-Men is
that as one of the most powerful
telepaths throughout the entirety of the
mutant population she had slightly
modified the mind of Dr stasis to
basically trick him into thinking that
Firestar had been feeding him
information the whole time it was a way
to basically keep her alive but at the
same time put at least one mutant in a
position to where they could gain
information on what orcas was doing but
what we end up finding out here is that
orcus is pretty hardcore right Mars was
at one point kind of a refuge for the
mutant population it's in the middle of
the Genesis War right now and it's in
the middle of a civil war we don't
really have a whole lot of information
on the Genesis war that hasn't
technically started yet and so we don't
know exactly how it's gonna play out but
suffice it to say 250
000 mutants which were on at that point
are now currently on Mars and who knows
what's going to happen to them they're
also putting them through these kind of
forced relocation camps where they're
actually performing gene therapy and
quote-unquote curing them of their
mutant illness the reality here is that
they're probably just performing some
pretty gruesome experiments on them but
the whole idea here is they basically
say unlike the mutant population who
lied to you and Who tricked you we're
keeping you informed we're keeping you
aware now one of the things that
seasoned X-Men readers will know is that
this Falls almost perfectly in line with
the events of Days of Future Past and to
a degree the original mutant Massacre
although that was massacring a whole
bunch of morlocks in the tunnels of New
York sewer systems so not exactly the
same thing but it really feels more like
a Days of Future Past event right
Humanity launching an attack against the
mutant population and then spinning it
to basically make it look like it is a
real and tangible event that benefits
Humanity now of course that led to them
activating the Sentinels and the
sentence took everything over but the
fact remains there are a few holdouts
here and there within the mutant
population right small pockets of
resistance the first among these is
Captain krakowa who was at one point
Cyclops and as far as I'm aware we don't
know the identity of the new version but
he's kind of like the mutant population
Zone version of like Captain America if
you want to call him that right kind of
like a superhero specifically for the
mutant population that kind of stands as
like the best of them but the other
thing about this is that feilong ends up
meeting with the president of the United
States now feilong is this guy who is
staunchly anti-mutant and as you guys
will notice from these giant Sentinels
these look like they're made from Stark
Tech that is an accurate statement that
did happen we will cover that because
basically Iron Man more or less
unwittingly ended up developing
Sentinels using Stark Tech that are
designed to hunt down the mutant
population but FEI Long kind of puts
this eye idea off right as a member of
orcas and kind of this anti-mutant group
he puts this idea out there that they've
done a few different things first and
foremost these Sentinels are stationed
throughout different places around the
world specifically areas where mutants
are most likely to congregate of course
krakowa being a perfect example because
what better place to try to rally what
few forces they have left than within
the mutant nation of krakowa itself
despite the fact that it's inaccessible
now while they have moved a whole bunch
of mutants right Force relocated them to
Mars what they've also done is they've
taken a whole bunch of their War Machine
non-man Sentinels and station them out
there at Phobos which is the moon that
orbits Mars in order to basically keep
Recon right to keep an eye on the planet
to see what they're doing and so what we
end up doing is transitioning to Dr
stasis when he's at one of the prison
facilities where these different mutants
are being held right the Henry guyrick
Center for Behavioral Studies which is
on Randall's Island the reason why it's
called the Henry guyrich Center for
Behavioral Studies is that back during
the Chris Claremont days in X-Men Henry
guyrick was very much an anti-mutant guy
and in fact he was a major focal point
in Project Wide Awake which was
basically a government-sanctioned
anti-mutant task force that stretched
from the highest levels of government
right the president Senators congressmen
congresswoman State Police local
sheriff's offices the FBI the CIA I mean
it was everything right just this
massive anti-mutant government
organization that actually kind of
operated in the dark that it was very
Cloak and Dagger but when Dr stasis is
here he ends up going into a room that's
holding quote unquote prisoner number
10. and as he's talking to this guy what
he's basically doing is telling him like
everything is done like it's over the
mutants are defeated the X-Men are gone
most mutants that are on Earth are
basically out and the ones who remain
here are these little small pockets of
resistance and oh Lordy me they may come
after us one day you know boohoo like
it's just one of these things things
worse kind of like game over you lost we
won join our side put forward our
anti-mutant rhetoric support the
statement that you guys attacked
humanity and will do you a courtesy
right you'll be treated better than
everybody else come to find out he's
talking to Cyclops now leaving out the
post Avengers vs X-Men landscape where
Cyclops was just a straight up villain
he's a good guy now right he's like he's
the Boy Scout what's really gruesome
about this is that in order to keep him
from being able to use his optic blast
they've sewn his eyes shut which is
pretty messed up but of course he won't
turn like he refuses to side against the
mutant population betray Xavier's dream
or anything along those lines and so for
the most part he's taunted right like
there's a ring of Sentinels around
kirkoa there's no safe haven for the
mutant population those X-Men who were
out there and are trying to like rally
their forces as best they can it's game
over but there's one thing going on here
that Dr stasis is not a accounting for
and I'm not even fully sure the fact
that he's aware of what's going on but
before we get to it what we do is we
pick up with Kitty Pride because one of
the things that had happened during the
Hellfire Gala and really even since the
beginning of Jonathan Hickman's X-Men is
that the krakowan gates are these Gates
designed by the mutants on krakowa that
will allow you to access the island no
matter where you are you could literally
plant a seed on some planet on the other
side of the universe it'll grow into a
door and when somebody passes through it
they'll end up on Earth in krakowa and
like it just it's awesome right it's a
really cool bit of tech Kitty Pride
could never enter in and out of those
doors despite the fact that she was a
mutant but when kakoa was taken down and
orcas shut down all the krakowan gates
suddenly she was able to enter in and
out of them it's kind of a Saving Grace
I don't really think this was the
intention of Marvel we never got an
answer for why she couldn't use the
gates before but it's kind of a cool way
to give her a unique ability here
because as the only person who can
access the Cohen Gates she's described
as a kind of ghost in the machine she
can segue in and out of these Gates and
no one's any other wiser to the fact
that she can do it because as far as
orcas and all these organizations are
concerned no mutant can enter in and out
of krakowa using krakowan Gates so she
really is their Ace in the Hole and in
fact sync an Omega Level mutant with the
power to duplicate the powers of anybody
else even he cannot enter in and out of
the gates despite his ability to
duplicate the powers of Kitty pride and
so that's why he tells her you're our
Ace in the Hole you're our secret weapon
you can get into places that people
should not be able to get into the
problem with this is that kitty pride
has taken a very dark turn and a lot of
this is because she's going back to the
days when she was operating as a student
of Logan what does that mean we'll talk
about that here in a little bit because
she gets this just like flat out amazing
moment but the reality here is that
Kitty pride is kind of operating on her
own agenda she's doing her own thing
she's not really following a plan that's
laid out by anybody in particular which
makes her Rogue but also makes her an
asset because it's very hard to
understand what she's doing now one of
the other big kickers here and this is
where the situation gets more
complicated the children of the Vault
they are getting their own tie-in for
the fall of X story so what we see here
is really more of just kind of setting
the stage for them but lest we forget
the children of the vault have largely
been isolated right they are these
individuals that exist inside this
literal Vault where time passes
differently one day in the real world is
something like a hundred years in the
vault which means they hyper evolve
their powers increase exponentially with
each new generation each one of these
children of the vault is more than
enough to crush some of the most
powerful mutants on earth when you have
an entire Army of them things get even
more difficult and all almost impossible
for anybody to confront the problem with
this is that the Vault was sealed shut
using the gates of krakowa but with
curcowen tech basically down and with
the gates themselves shut down now the
children of the Vault are available to
roam free they have a vendetta against
the X-Men but the question has to be
asked what goes on here when you have
them directly targeting any and
everybody who stands against the mutant
population even if the children of the
Vault are not necessarily mutants per se
now it does deal with Miss Marvel to a
degree we'll talk about this the thing
about Miss Marvel of course like she
died an Amazing Spider-Man number 26 and
then she came back as a mutant and so
people are like how's Marvel going to
reconcile like the idea that like her
family knows she died Emma Frost shows
up to her house messes with their minds
fixes everything so now that's that's
the whole thing with her so the thing
about this is once they get back to the
sewer systems and you get this really
really cool meeting between Emma Frost
who's actually masquerading as a woman
named Hazel as well as Kitty Pride who
arrives on the scene the thing that I
was talking about when I was referring
to this sort of secret situation that
orcas doesn't really seem to be aware of
is Captain America's Unity Squad so for
those of you guys who don't know about
this the unity Squad was formed in
Marvel Comics in the aftermath of
Avengers vs X-Men the two groups fought
each other over the return of the
Phoenix Captain America came to the
realization that they're actually
greater than the sum of their parts so
in order to kind of bridge this Rift
between the two of them they decided to
basically merge mutants and Avengers
onto a singular team and the unity Squad
was dope it was one of the coolest
things that Marvel had for the longest
time and now you have it again which is
why you have Iron Man you've got
Deadpool of course Iron Man's here
because he was more or less tricked and
it wasn't really even him building it
per se but Stark Tech was used to build
the Sentinels but it's one of these
things where Captain America and the
remnants of the mutant population on
Earth basically meet in different
locations it's never in the same place
twice and they never meet for long they
exchange information and it really is in
effect Captain America putting on the
front face that like he's an Avenger and
the Avengers are dealing with threats
that don't involve the Newton population
but all the while keeping his ear to the
ground and feeding information to the
mutant resistance group to basically
keep them aware of what's going on out
there in the world because they can't
just like go out there and do their
thing but what happens and this is where
we get into this discussion about like
kitty Pride's amazing moment ogan that
whole thing which is dope wolf range
training and all that stuff what we end
up getting is this moment where Emma
Frost asks Kitty Pride when the initial
attack on Orcas happened and you fell
through the Cocoon gate what happened
because we didn't immediately find out
all we saw was Kitty Pride falling
through the gate and then we immediately
pick up with this story what we end up
learning is that she lands in Jerusalem
and when she gets there that immediately
the gate is shut down and she's met by
all these different soldiers and in in
that moment she has to make an immediate
decision and that's when the training of
ogan kicks in so who is Logan Logan is a
person in Marvel Comics that is
exceedingly old and has a really kind of
a relationship with both Wolverine as
well as Kitty Pride it's more of like a
mentor relationship but Logan was the
one that taught Wolverine to kind of
control his animal side so when you go
from like Wolverine's history when he's
like out there in the Canadian
wilderness and living like an animal and
then suddenly he's with like Alpha
flight and he seems more human ogan is
where that transition took place the
other thing is that ogan trained
Wolverine at least was one of the many
people who trained Wolverine in martial
arts because ogan was a ninja Logan
eventually trained Kitty Pride but she's
also been trained by Wolverine as well
but she always had this part of her that
was like when it comes down to the wire
that training kicks in she almost goes
into autopilot to a degree I wouldn't
quite call it a Berserker rage or
anything like that but her training
kicks in and then she literally just
shut everybody down and that's exactly
what happens here in this moment when
she falls through the gates and then she
hears the radio broadcast that the gates
have been shut down that immediately
informs her orcus has total control over
the curcumen transit system they decide
who gets in and who gets out the fact
that she was able to fall through it I
mean she's one of the only people really
the only person as far as she's aware
that can access it that information is
worth killing for because if they
discovered she could do this they would
kill her so in response she immediately
kills everybody on the spot and she does
it in like the most amazing way because
she's surrounded by like 10 guys now
normally the X-Men don't kill but given
the circumstance it's perfectly okay the
first thing she does she grabs this
guy's hand and because Kitty Pride can
phase through objects but can also make
objects face through other things she
forces this guy's gun to phase through
his head and then makes it tangible
kills him on the spot then she smashes
another guy's head into the ground one
guy comes running at her so then she
uses his momentum throws him into
another guy and because he's intangible
he basically merges with this other guy
so it's like two humans who are just
kind of combined together she kicks a
dude in the balls she sinks down into
the ground and this guy is half sticking
in the ground right just the cement
kills him and then you have two more
guys who start shooting at her of course
she's able to face like the bullets go
right through her she grabs their
grenades pulls the pins throws them at
him and then they both blow up and it's
amazing because there's this final guy
there who basically begs for Mercy right
like he literally says like no no please
don't kill me please don't kill me like
the X-Men saved me at one point and
she's like yeah that's what the X-Men do
we save people even if there are worse
enemies and she breaks his neck on the
spot now somebody to understand this is
one of those things where again it's
similar to Wolverine's Berserker rage
the the training kicks in the adrenaline
kicks in she deals with the problem and
then as soon as this all said and done
she comes to terms with what she did and
she realizes she's now become a killer
she's basically an assassin but this is
one of those moments in Marvel Comics
when they take a character who has
historically been somebody who can kind
of do some cool things sometimes I guess
and they turn him into just a baller
character because now Kitty pride is one
of the deadliest people on Earth and I
would even argue in the universe right
just that level because I mean how do
you kill a person that you can't touch
right like a person that can touch you
but you can't touch them how do you
defeat them or how do you destroy that
person it's just it's amazing right I
mean I wouldn't say she's like a beyond
omega level character at this point but
I will say her level of strength and
power is Way Beyond anything she's been
before and so she basically tells Emma
Frost I'm gonna go kill Firestar because
she doesn't know that Firestar is a
friendly X-Man and the fire star is
working for them it's just Jean Gray
screwed up the mind of everybody in
orcas and tricked them into thinking
that Firestar has been working with them
the whole time and so what we end up
doing here is transitioning to Iceman
because Iceman is alive in Marvel Comics
and I know it sounds strange because
during the Hellfire Gala comic he was
killed he was destroyed by Nimrod the
ultimate Sentinel right part of orcasus
forces the being this design to take out
Omega Level mutants right it's the first
thing they attacked the most powerful
mutants who were out there and what
Iceman says is that cellular Napalm was
used to basically melt him from the
inside out that it was some of the worst
pain he'd ever experienced and in fact
he actually died on the spot but one of
the last things he did is he reached for
Romeo and Romeo had to watch him die why
does this matter this was the result of
Marvel coming out and saying that like
Bobby Drake was gay and that he had a
partner I don't really know why that
mattered to people he was still an
amazing character but the thing about
this is that uh Romeo is an inhuman that
adds the ability to tap into other
people's empathy and his own empathy
meaning he can sense People based on how
they feel now this is one of those
instances where Marvel just kind of
modifies how his powers work for the
sake of being able to tell a story but
what we end up finding out here is that
while everybody else had assumed that
Bobby Drake was dead Romeo did not and
so Romeo felt like somewhere out there
in the world was like the emotional
essence of Bobby Drake right kind of
like a an emotional Echo if you could
say that right I mean by all standards
the measurement he was dead and so as
Romeo started making his way through the
world he basically Came Upon what we
could really argue as being Iceman's
Fortress of Solitude right which I think
is kind of an amazing thing right truth
to tell but he ended up picking up this
kind of emotional point of Bobby Drake
and when he touched it he was able to
tie or at least connect to Bobby Drake's
emotions and effectively bring him back
from the dead right the two of them
Embrace and in that moment Bobby Drake
returns is it like a super hand wavy
method of explaining the return of a
character who died absolutely it is
right I mean it's lazy riding in the
most extreme but it is a really really
cool thing to see that this guy's come
back so for those of you guys who are
not caught up with the fall of X event
make sure you click this playlist it'll
get you caught up on everything that's
happened so far we're only like two
videos and thank you all for watching
and I will catch you all later
peace